Where is the acid?
My staff hears me say this more
than they probably care to remember.
But, "where is the acid?"
is really the central
question when we create a new dish.
When seasoning foods, everyone
talks about salt. I believe acid
is just as important, maybe
more important than salt.
When I grew up in Switzerland, I
was always drawn to acidic foods.
I love tomatoes.
I love citrus fruits.
I love pickles.
My mom's cooking-- sauerkraut, roasted
chicken with lemon and rosemary.
She made a braised rabbit with
olives, orange, and pickled onions.
I never knew exactly why I
was drawn to these dishes
so much, why they were my favorite.
But looking back, it
makes sense, because there
was presence of acid, which gave it
balance, and it highlighted the food.
And it just makes food better.
Acid just makes food better.
At Eleven Madison, we serve
tasting menus-- 14, 15, 16 courses.
It's important that all
these dishes have acid.
We use acid from so
many different sources.
But it keeps the guests excited,
it keeps the meal lighter,
and it makes the guests want more.
So, what is an acid?
An acid, by definition, is a molecule
that releases a hydrogen ion.
And so here is an image of citric
acid releasing a hydrogen ion.
And this measure of
how strong an acid is,
is a measure of how easily an
acid gives up that hydrogen ion.
And so, for example, citric acid gives
up the hydrogen ion not as easily
as, say, sulfuric acid does,
which we use in car batteries.
The hydrogen ion is
taken up by the water,
and it's giving us-- instead of an
H2O, it's giving us an H3O plus.
And this is usually referred
to as a hydronium ion.
So, how acidic something
is, then, is a measure
of how easily hydrogen
ions are given off.
And we usually also refer
to hydrogen ions as protons.
And the more hydrogen
ions and, indirectly,
how many hydronium
ions there are around,
is what gives us a measure
of how acidic something is.
So, it turns out that the number
of hydrogen ions in water,
naturally, is 10 to the power
of negative 7 moles per liter,
in a liter of water.
In fact, there is 55 moles
of molecules per liter.
And so 10 to the negative 7, then,
is actually a very, very tiny amount.
But, nevertheless, this is how many
hydrogen ions there are in water.
Water is thought of
being neutral, and acids
are molecules that easily give up
hydrogen ions, and so they're acidic.
And so, then, at the
other end of the spectrum,
we have molecules that
are very, very reluctant
to give up hydrogen ions,
even more so than water.
And those we think of as
bases, or basic molecules.
And there is a mathematical
formula for this,
which is pH equals minus the logarithm
of how many moles per liter of hydrogen
ions we have.
And so if we do this for water, where
we know that the number of hydrogen
ions 10 to the negative 7, and
we plug this into this formula,
we say minus the logarithm
of 10 to the negative 7.
And for those of you who are
comfortable with logarithms,
you immediately see that
the answer to this is 7.
And if you're not, you can
plug this into your calculator
and actually see that
the number for this is 7.
And so the pH of water is 7.
And this is something that a lot
of us are very familiar with,
and if not, this is a good reminder.
We're using a pH meter
at the restaurant.
And we're using it as a measure to give
us more consistency, more accuracy.
We're using it in a way we use a scale,
or in a way we measure temperature.
So we took our still water, and this
is the water we serve with our meal,
and we measured it at 7.5.
7 is neutral, so it's
very close to neutral.
We also looked at the
manufactured foods.
Coca-Cola is more acidic
than red wine vinegar.
Just imagine that.
Isn't that crazy?
You eat that with your meal.
It's more acidic than red wine vinegar.
That's unbelievable.
And when you drink Coca-Cola, you
never think of it as being acidic.
And that's because there's so much
sugar to balance all that acid,
and makes it a beverage
that everyone loves.